i want i want to go back to uh this
woman the uh the ministry of truth we
have this tweet from christina pascha oh
you can see i retweeted it she says
biden's minister of truth force away
lock us down this is what we want we
want to be criticizing this lady is the
definition of unwell what she she's
supposed to be this disinformation
person you know executive director
whatever the government says whatever
the authority says is true that's her
attitude she tweeted long story short i
think we as a country might be too um
free spirited to put it diplomatically
to comply with social distancing
recommendations unless they're forced
upon us
so force away lock us down people are
not taking this seriously wow
now that was from march and that was
still a rather extreme position
americans are two free spirits remember
when fouchy said it's time to shut up
and do as you're told yeah yeah these
people are nuts well it blows my mind
because she was saying this in 2020
right yeah so
she was saying this again
under the trump administration
because i used i used to have this
theory where it's like okay
you know leftists think they're always
going to be in power and when they're in
power they want all these new government
powers and authorities and and whatnot
because
they trust their own people to do it but
one of these days they're going to get
somebody that they recognize oh this is
the problem because i don't want i don't
want this guy having this much power
and and i've come to the realization
that they they seem to like it
yeah masochism you're talking about it's
just well this idea of government
authority and power and somebody telling
them what to do and what the right
answer is and i again i always thought
that
clearly they're going to understand at
some level i don't want everyone anyone
to have that's president to have this
power
and i'm i'm starting to think that's not
true and it's crazy to me well i would
disagree to some extent i hear what
you're saying but i think the reason
that they support it is because all of
the people forcing their worldview and
everyone else who has any level of power
right now is on the left and so what
they appreciate is the fact that people
who would not obey them are being forced
to by the state
and so ultimately because as soon as you
have someone like elon musk come in
and who is you know potentially going to
be the owner of twitter here and
simply says i'm just not gonna bully the
people you want me to bully they
completely lose their minds so it's not
so much that they like having decisions
made for them though i think there's an
element of that there i think
they love making decisions for you
they're they're the the most conforming
anti-conformist i've ever heard well not
not only did you tweet this
authoritarian nonsense she has several
tweets like that she's also outright
spread disinformation herself where she
said the hunter biden laptop story was
trump a product of the trump campaign
things like that
so are we are we really supposed to
assume
that they have the the best intentions
no no no i think as i stated earlier if
you create a store called like swords
and things i would assume you're selling
those things i wouldn't assume you're
trying to stop those things from being
sold so when they create the
disinformation governance board and put
a woman in charge of it who sows
disinformation i think the purpose is
entirely clear
just lying to us about what they're
trying to sell to the american people
she must have a bunch of self-hatred
because when she's saying force me and
lock me down um that's really disgusting
and masochistic of like self-hate type
of thing yeah i don't know some people
are into it you know she maybe she's
like yeah but you know daddy government
not to the maybe yeah but that's
masochistic to have this kind of psycho
psychopathy in in power is is
devastating she also said this jack
pasok as his tweet in 2020 she said that
the executive branch shouldn't have the
power to determine what is fake news she
then goes on to say that it's fake news
that facebook has a bias against
conservatives and then adds she's she's
funded by facebook so uh sure
she was uh right in the first point the
federal government i'm sorry the
executive branch shouldn't have the
authority to determine what's fake news
now she quite literally works for the
department of homeland security under
joe biden determining what is fake news
brilliant quite amazing but this is to
my point that they're fine it's just a
product of them wanting to force their
world view on other people right i mean
so when it's the trump administration no
the government doesn't have the ability
to determine what's true or what's false
but as soon as biden's in office i mean
it's unsurprising right it feels very
much like nazi germany man
like 1932 when they set up that board of
what is a ministry of it was goebels
go balls pardon me yeah the propaganda
again i
the the thing that blows my mind about
all of this is that there there's this
overwhelming faith in government power
in order to achieve certain positive
ends and again going back to thomas soul
because i do that regularly
it's this whole idea of the government
doesn't deal in solutions the government
deals in trade-offs but if you've if
you've built in your mind that really
what this is about is government
wielding power to compel people to do
the right thing and really this is just
a question of getting the right people
in the position to be able to wield that
sort of authority well then this kind of
makes sense if you understand that
people are fallible therefore the people
in political power are fallible then
you're a lot more cautious about them
having this kind of authoritarian power
over things and it is amazing to me that
we are not that far away from when you
had legitimately you know we still do
have
violent communist governments that are
suppressing speech suppressing their own
populations and doing so through
propaganda government-controlled
propaganda and to think this is an okay
idea and then it's coming from the left
right the very people that used to like
stick it to the man are you kidding me
well let's uh i'm gonna do something
else right now i am going to defend this
woman not because of this video jack
bosobic tweeted out meet the biden dhs
national head of censorship please do
not retweet this video as it may upset
your new internet overlords
i don't really want to play this do i
have to play it's really gross but yeah
probably i'm going to play it guys i'm
really sorry you have to hear this one
all right but we're going to play don't
play at all though seeing them in
congress or a mainstream outlet so
disinformation's origins are slightly
less
fake atrocious it's how you hide a
delighted lie it's how you hide a little
light a little lie it's how you hide
little idols alive when rudy giuliani
shared that intel from ukraine or when
tick tock influences take over it can
cause pain ah it hurts she put that on
tick tock that ccp tech she put that on
tick tock and i you know i saw this
video i did say i was going to defend
her and i will but when i saw this video
i thought to myself
i think there's something about
left-leaning millennials where they
never grew up the world is harry potter
yeah voldemort's the you know everyone's
voldemort and they post these videos on
tick tock as if they're children
like
i'm sorry
ma'am you're in your late 30s
and you're heading up a government
institution and you're singing mary
poppins
i just i feel like these people are
children
yeah i mean they reject adulthood they
reject responsibility ultimately i think
that
well i think that's a lot of where the
the gender insanity comes from as well
part of becoming an adult is being
firmly rooted in either your masculinity
and your femininity and if you are
called to marriage starting a family
having children but they completely
reject that responsibility and so they
start to reject the concept of gender
altogether i'm going to defend this
woman because my point is that not
gender sexuality you were allowed to
have a nonsense term you're allowed to
have fun and do fun things and have
hobbies if you're older and you like
skateboarding perhaps some people are
like you're too old for that no you're
it's good exercise maybe you like
playing magic together and hey hobbies
are fantastic fun ways to exercise your
mind or your body i got no issue you
want to sing songs that's great but in
your job as a disinformation expert
singing about this weird stuff you're
starting to get a little weird with it
but here's where i where i will defend
her jack bosobic tweeted this out and i
think he should not have we you know
we're good friends with jack but i think
he should not have posted this it's he
wrote i saw it so you have to see it and
it's a video apparently of this woman in
college with another woman
and
i did not mean to play that it is not
good it didn't sound bad it is not good
okay um it's it's d plus material c
minus maybe but i'm not here to make fun
of a woman who was in college and wrote
wrote a song with her friend and just
filmed it put it on the internet i think
that's fine she did if i saw if this
video came out today and it was on tick
tock i'd be like hey keep it up guys you
know keep keep working hard keep
practicing keep it right and one day
you're gonna hit that number one you
know i would encourage young people to
do good stuff we also have this one
from the daily caller flashback video of
biden's minister of truth thinking about
effing her way to fame and power the
vibes are horrendous no no no this is
stupid she's she she's making a point in
this song she's singing i want to play
it because it's actually you you might
not like it but she is good at what she
is doing in the song she's talking about
how she's talented and works hard but
isn't notable or famous it's a bit it's
a musical she then says who do i have to
f to get fame and power the bit is that
in hollywood that's how you do it she's
making fun of hollywood and everyone
laughs i'm going to play a little bit at
first singing just so you can hear
well i seriously doubt it but she was
rich
[Music]
she's actually really good it doesn't
surprise me she's a theater major like a
theater actor to be the propaganda
minister
absolutely someone who knows how to do
that performance what bugs me about this
is they took the one thing she's good at
and then plastered on the internet she's
okay she's not even that good she's
singing from her chest she needs to sing
from her core she's gesticulating her
posture is really bad her shoulders are
all hunched like she could be a lot
better she's sure sure she's 98 good and
she's going to fact-check everything you
said i was like actually
from your hands
i am i am not here to give you a do i'm
not i'm not here to give her a tony
i'm just here to point out that
she's singing well people are enjoying
it they're having a good time she's
probably cool don't personally but
doesn't mean she's not a size i don't
know i don't think she's misinformed i
think she's nuts but why would you
highlight something that
is like a positive about her to try and
own her like when they showed aoc
dancing on the rooftop and they're like
look at her and i'm like a college
student having fun am i supposed to you
think that makes her look not cool it
makes her look personal
i think there's something i think
there's something of a generational
difference here too with respect to
what one generation tends to think as
this is something that discredits a
person versus what a younger generation
thinks discredits a person so i think
some of this is is a is a misread of you
know how are you going to influence your
audience with respect to how to think
about her so like i i see this i'm like
she's actually a pretty good singer
like this doesn't this doesn't strike me
as oh well gosh that's why i have a
problem with her it's not because she's
the authoritarian czar of a government
disinformation
exactly so yeah yeah also with the aoc
thing
so much of that was manufactured i don't
think i knew anyone who was upset about
her dancing because i don't live in the
film footloose do you know a single
conservative who was genuinely mad at
her for dancing i don't think it was
the majority but there were people on
twitter who are constantly making fun of
her for it well
okay there was one thing that was done
with that whole thing that i did think
was funny and that was they showed her
dancing and then the thing said when
you're first in line for the breadline
right
that makes funny because she's you know
she's a socialist and make memes out of
it for sure yeah absolutely and i'm you
know i think that's fantastic but i
didn't know anyone who was genuinely
upset like oh she danced how horrific
this this clip from the daily caller and
i think the clip jackpot pointed out
it's like guys you're reaching
dude yeah but that first one wasn't
reaching where she's like
rudy julian
is a political political politics crowd
that's what she was spreading she was
spreading misinformation in that little
cutie mary poppins song she was singing
and that was directly relevant to the
job she is now going to be that was more
exactly
and real quick i think people saw that
and criticized it which is warranted and
then grabbed other stuff of her singing
as if it was bad that she sang yeah no
no no
yeah also i mean we understand the
concepts of information and
misinformation differently than the left
does and that is to say we understand
these concepts correctly because we
understand that the purpose of
information is to help a person form
their world view so that they can know
the truth the left sees information the
value of information is anything that
helps them reach the end of bringing
their political worldview to fruition
and so to them misinformation means
anything that gets in the way of the
social order i'm seeking to establish
which is why they were constantly saying
that they were trying to crack down on
misinformation even though the things
they labeled as misinformation were then
revealed to be true and they never
walked their policies back i just want
to point out i think it's funny like you
know that we're all here like this
lady's spreading dangerous
disinformation and then ian's like she's
she's singing from the chest so her
shoulders are crunched up she wants to
get better i'm sure she's getting to the
heart of the problem he'll be better no
i think i'm just saying like her name
ian j
you took theater yeah so you're seeing
it from a different angle from us where
ours is purely political and he's
looking at her performance like no no
her shoulders it's like relax your
shoulders you know let your head fall
back and your keep your chin low and so
to your point i i think this is we we
were having this debate a while back um
and it was the whole idea of
post-modernism and deconstructionism it
was the idea of what is the philosophy
which informs the left and the way they
think about these things so when you've
accepted that there is no such thing as
absolute truth whether it be moral or
just you know factual and this is all a
question of power structure and it's all
a question of which group is going to
dominate the power structure in order to
help their group or their tribe or
whatever it is you're absolutely right
misinformation is no longer this idea of
what is actually true because there is
no objective truth there's just power
struggles and right now they want their
they want their group to be on top and
the way that you do that is by
controlling the flow of information and
they honestly believe it's going to
produce positive results for the people
that they care about right so it's it's
not as if they they have purely
nefarious and we would consider it
nefarious because we think it's rooted
in a lie but they can actually convince
themselves i'm doing a good and noble
thing on behalf of marginalized
populations and anything that stands in
the way of achieving that for your
so-called truth
is irrelevant yeah this is also
sometimes known as the problem of moral
licensing so this idea that because i'm
a good person with good motives anything
that i want to do is acceptable in order
to achieve that goal and of course what
always ends up happening when you hold
that position is you just become a bad
person and then the fruits of your
endeavors tend to be horrible as well
guys yeah i think
i know what we need to do oh we need to
get nina jankowicz cast in a broadway
musical
we need to allow her to take her talents
and run with it ian stop criticizing her
abilities no no because you remember
what happened last time an art student
dropped out oh my gosh
wow
did they make 1984 i'll never give up on
you nina
ian will instruct you he will teach you
how to sing there was another art of
broadway there was another thread no one
believed him couldn't draw people
and was criticized for it is that really
what it was that was a big part he had a
hard time drawing the human form that is
fascinating that is fascinating well
yeah and just that an authoritarian
despot who murdered people failed to see
individuals as what they were was that
before the world war one his trench
warfare in world war one or after
as far as like getting when he got
rejected from our yeah oh that was i'm
pretty sure that was after world war one
but i don't know i think i think he
started before but i'm just waiting for
media matters to write oh yeah tim poole
compares nina to hitler
because she sings
the disinformation board to the nazis
disinformation board but that's about it
yeah i haven't hasn't done anything
except for that cringe musical yeah i
have i have to admit when that first
like press release came out describing
what it was like i
as i'm reading it i'm hearing it in a
german accent america like the
department of homeland security
stuff they've been doing anyway behind
the scenes now they're just codifying it
somebody somebody super chatted saying
twitter was their disinformation
government board yeah yep and how elon
bought it so they're like all right just
do it through the government
yeah clearly we cannot rely on the
private sector to do this properly we
have to step in for ourselves you have
to crack a few eggs if you want some
omelette
how do you stop a government like our
government from doing stuff like that
like we're supposed to vote the right
people in so that they stop it from the
inside what was your answer lawsuit i
think they're gonna get i think the
government's gonna get sued on on first
amendment grounds and the disinformation
board will be disbanded overnight it
can't last the the first step is always
you know vote for the right people right
theoretically if the right people are
running second is um yeah you you sue
the government you actually use the
separation of powers in order to do it
and the third one is is
you know it's the passive resistance
right it's the peaceful resistance
government it's like i'm not going to
comply with this let's see how much you
really want to enforce it yeah they'll
go to like um twitter's board or they'll
go to the developers and give them a gag
order and say give me your code give me
your login info and the people be like
well if i don't then the feds are going
to come raid my house and put me in a
prison for a year without seeing anyone
so they do it but if a way to passively
resist that is to get rid of the
centralized services so you as a tech
company don't control the login data or
the password data it's encrypted and
unavailable you ever see shane did you
see that south park episode where
they're imagining george lucas and
steven spielberg ruining indiana jones
no i don't i don't so it's like didn't
they already do that with the fourth one
yeah there's a scene where it's like i
think it's like deliverance and there's
two you know like redneck guys and
they're like you look mighty good and
they like take indiana jones and they go
at them and i was just thinking like
based off what you were saying about
income tax and stuff it'd be funny to do
that scene but it's the government
taking your income tax like hey there
boy that income's looking mighty good
it's like no stay away federal
government i'm coming yeah well the
income tax is another one of these
things that's just part of the status
quo now so people don't understand how
unbelievably insane it is especially at
its current rates the idea that just
working and being productive results in
you being penalized by the government
taking your wealth from you i would love
to have an expert on the show to go deep
on the history of income tax it got
started 1913 are you familiar so it's
technically technically it actually
started under lincoln
lincoln was the first person to actually
level like a federal income tax and was
ordered to pay for the civil war
but yeah did it become like truly
constitutional the way we have now until
you actually pass the
14th 16th 16th 16th amendment yeah six
of them with the constitution it was
fascinating because the original debate
was all right we're gonna we're gonna do
this right but it's only gonna affect
this portion of the population and we're
gonna cap it at three percent and you
actually people going wait i thought you
said one percent you can't you can't put
it at three percent if you put it in
three percent they'll actually take all
three percent
and now
i'm i'm way wrong on 14 16 right
income tax amount 14 is the one they're
trying to get margery taylor green on
yeah dude did you see her talk to uh
what's his name the
reporter yeah acosta he was trailing her
and kept asking and she's like just pull
up the text you're talking about read it
out loud right now
and he did and it basically shows
exactly what she was saying is true that
she was like questioning martial law
so it
misinformation is any information that
is bad for the regime or used against
the regime so right now
if uh you
mow someone's lawn for 10 bucks
you got to then when you see that 10
bucks you got to give the government
depending on your tax bracket between
like 27 or 37 maybe even more and that's
just for the income tax now if you're
running a business you've got to split
the employment tax is going to be 7.5 on
the business end 7.5 on the person's end
and so that typically goes in with the
income tax but now now you're running a
business right you get ten bucks the
business takes the ten dollars you then
say okay now what do i do i'm going to
pay myself because i'm the employee of
my business so i got to give 27 to the
government then i got to give the
business has to give 7.5 percent to the
government so now you're actually at you
know about 36 or you know what are we
looking at 35 percent
then you've got then you take that money
say okay great now i'm going to buy the
fuel i need for my lawn lawnmower
and then when you go and buy that fuel
you got to give the government another
cut for the for the sales tax and the
gas tax
you see it just it just it's going to be
it's going to be taxed at every single
level at a certain point like if you
basically if you want to make four
dollars you have to make ten dollars
right
every every aspect of monetary exchange
is taxed and that's just too much so
it's really difficult to have an
argument with a libertarian when they're
like taxation is theft and i'm like well
technically at this well now it is yeah
like you want if you come to me and you
say that taxation makes sense in these
certain contexts where it's like
the roads everyone loves that argument
i'm like well look i i think
taxation
is fine maybe maybe the income tax is
not but certain taxation i have no issue
with to a certain degree like the
founding fathers even said taxation but
we should have representation we're at
the point now where it's like literally
everything you do is taxed now they want
to tax how many miles you drove on your
car it's like dude already bought the
car i bought the gas the gas was already
taxed for how much i was going to drive
i'm gonna tax my car by seeing the
odometer now if i sell the car gotta pay
another tax but i bought i gotta pay a
tax if i get the money i gotta pay tax
everything you do then you die they tax
you again well i i love that the when it
whenever they make this stupid argument
that i can't believe that warren buffett
pays less in taxes than a secretary bull
crap all right he plays a much higher
income tax rate the difference is the
capital gains versus there shouldn't be
a capital gains i mean it's a form of
double taxation so i i got my money
through income i then pay taxes on that
income i then take some of what's left
over and i reinvest it into something
that helps somebody else start a
business or hire more people or expand
their operation in the hopes that maybe
one day i will actually receive a profit
from selling this and then you're going
to tax it again
and now it's at a slightly lower rate
and so that's where they come up with
this justification and it's just crazy
to me because ultimately what we're
doing is we're disincentivizing
productivity right
yeah gambling tax actually the stupidest
one people don't realize that when you
wager one dollar so say you put you put
ten bucks down on on roulette you say
ten ten bucks on red
you win ten bucks you owe the government
two dollars and eighty cents so you're
wagering ten dollars for a chance to win
less than ten dollars like there's
there's a tax on all of those winnings
and then uh you can't you can't claim
losses on more than you've gambled so if
you walk in with 100 bucks and lose it
that's too bad
you can't claim claim a loss on that
unless you're professional gambler yeah
so also like when you look at biden's
policies in his proposed policies with
respect to capital gain tax one way he
plans on taxing the rich quote unquote
is to have everyone who makes more than
a million dollars have their capital
gains tax increase from 20 to 40 and the
idea is well that's only going to hurt
rich people but obviously if you are a
wealthy person you are not going to bet
100 of your own money to only
potentially keep 60 of the winnings
because that's an idiotic move to make
and so small businesses
that need investment from wealthier
people just aren't going to end up being
formed if that policy ever takes effect
well and you know what they're going to
do it's they're always going to accept
invest they're always going to exempt if
you buy government bonds so if you want
to give the money if you want to give
your money to the government and get a
guaranteed three percent interest or
whatnot oh yeah sure you can do that all
day long they'll make all kinds of
exceptions for that but if you actually
want to invest in a private enterprise
well now all of a sudden we want to we
want to tax the hell out of you and this
unrealized gains is the biggest bs it's
complete nonsense it's it's literally
money that you haven't made there's no
such thing as an unrealized that's why
it's called unrealized it's literally
they're taxing something you don't have
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time